[Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [ __ ]  [Applause]  [Music]  now get get out of there  you've been so stressed lately but this  vet is gonna help you he specializes in  behavioral disorders but I don't have a  behavioral disorder  yeah I'm fine too it's by humans it's  nuts  I mean you know I I bring him a dead  bird she throws it out  [Music]  get out and I've gone know someone's in  my litter box do any of you know captain  snowball and here we go  it's no time  is he okay not in any way No  [Music]  no no no this way buddy well the baby is  leaving in nest oh he's staying home  with me where it's safe  three max Liam just left wait what  it's home base to all units the package  has left the building does anyone have  eyes on him  [Music]  [Music]  the first step of not being afraid is  acting like you're not afraid  [Music]  Wow  just this weird little guy  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]